the las vegas cycling community  continues to grow and now it's going to  be partnering with one of the most  famous races in the world the tour de  france bringing a new event to town  called latap it'll happen may of next  year and the event will bring local  cyclists all together at the las vegas  ballpark before setting off on rides  into red rock  all of the eyeballs on  the tour de france in this event it's  really going to raise the awareness of  cycling on the road and and cyclists on  the road and that's just going to  emphasize and promote our message the  bike coalition's message of bicycle  safety  there will be several distances really  depending on your experience level even  a family ride that's open to everybody  so the setup at the ballpark will also  include an athlete's village as well as  a tour de france museum